- Joining us from Glasgow,
please welcome Sam Heughan, everybody.
(crowd cheering)
Oh, my God.
What's up, Sam?
Those were some nice moves
and a nice kilt, man.
- Oh, Kelly, I can't
believe you showed that one.
(crowd laughing)
C'mon.
- That's why it's amazing.
- I know.
- Is a kilt your usual attire?
- I mean, it's not really.
Obviously, in the show, Men In Kilts,
we do wear a lot of kilts.
And just for you, Kelly,
the director of your show wanted me
to show them what I was
wearing, but I refused,
I wanted to save this for you.
But I wore this, especially for you.
- Yeah!
Woo!
(Kelly laughing)
(crowd cheering and laughing)
I'm just saying, a real man
wears a kilt and owns it.
That's a real man.
I know what a family tartan is,
but I know a lot of people might not.
What is that?
- Yeah, I mean, it's
traditionally every family,
every clan has their own tartan,
and it dates back kind of
to the Victorian times.
Before that point, there
were tartans associated
with different clans, different
motto, different houses.
But yeah, it was made more traditional
in the Victorian times.
We wear a variety of kilts
and tartans in the show.
And this one I was
wearing today, actually,
is the Outlander tartan.
- Oh, that's so cool.
Have you ever accidentally
flashed someone in your kilt?
And, but by the way, you
probably did it on purpose.
But have you ever accidentally done it?
(crowd laughing)
- Do you know what?
I think I almost flashed
you there, actually.
I didn't mean to, but yeah.
(Kelly laughing)
I mean, not intentionally but you know,
it's kind of dangerous.
It's a kind of extreme
sport, wearing a kilt.
And in Men In Kilts,
we do a lot of things.
We're riding bicycles, we're abseiling,
you guys call it repelling.
We're hiking, we're doing
all kinds of sports in kilts.
So I'm sure at some point,
if you look closely,
you might see something
you don't wanna see.
- Oh, my gosh.
Or maybe they do?